Let's go to a caller from the four one three
area code loves seeing four one, three, uh,
Western Massachusetts caller from four one
three.
What's going on?
Hey, how's it going, David?
Good.
How are you?
Not too bad.
I'm just calling regarding a topic that you
briefly touched on before, but you didn't
really have a chance to expand on another
time.
Uh, you were talking about, uh, legalization
of drugs and you're mostly for it, but you
had some reservations.
I personally have always kind of been of mindset.
All drugs should be legal as long as the child,
they're not, as long as you're not able to
sell it to minors, you're not hurting anyone.
But it sounded like you had some reservations.
I was kind of curious what your reservations
about legalize.
So my, my reservations are merely, I mean,
so here's basically my thought.
I want to decriminalize all drugs for sure.
I want to legalize many of them.
I just am unsure about the net effect of legalizing,
uh, black tar heroin for recreational use.
I'm just, I'm just not sure about that.
I've not, I've heard good arguments for and
against.
So I'm clear on decriminalization.
I'm clear on legalization of many drugs just
on the, the, the, the recreational legalization
of cocaine and heroin and stuff like that.
I'm just unsure about.
But outside of, I understand, I sort of had
an understanding, but outside of the, the
effects that drugs could happen, someone and
the potential be seen, just behaviors that
they can partake in, such as, for example,
driving under the influence, which is already
illegal or assaulting someone or whatever.
These are behaviors that may be in Flint,
but those behaviors are already illegal, right?
So
they are here.
So here's what my concern would be.
Here's where my concern would be with some
of these drugs.
The at, in any dose.
They are so destructive to the individual
that it's hard for me to imagine them not
becoming destructive to society.
So if you say, listen, someone's going to
smoke pot in their house, they're not going
to drive, it's illegal to do that anyway.
It's very clear that people can smoke pot
or have edibles or whatever in a way that
is not going to have a broader negative effect
on society.
Something like a heroin for example, I just
don't know if it's use is truly just limited
to the individual who's choosing to use it.
And that's it.
I don't know how if you have children, there's
any way you can just use heroin and it not
affect children.
I don't know if you have a job, if there's
any way that you can use heroin and have it
not affect the people you work with and whoever
the customers are of the business.
That's where I get hung up on recreational
legalization of some of the harder drugs and
I'm willing to have my mind changed for sure.
Okay.
All right.
Um, I mean I still don't totally agree, but
I'm, I, I definitely don't have the time to
go back and forth with you, but I definitely
appreciate your, your, your take on it.
All right.
Where are you calling from by the way?
Oh yeah, I'm actually, I am calling from Connecticut.
I was originally in Springfield, mass.
Oh, all right.
Very good.
All right, very good.
Always looking at her from the four Oh one
three area code.
Thank you so much.